[Music]
but also [ __ ] OJ's on Twitter which
is crazy and how many followers does oj
have on twitter like the fact that he
has any is bad if you follow Oh J on
Twitter
chu doon like what are you doing dude he
has I always pull up the wrong one
how about fake accounts dude this
[ __ ] kills me when somebody like I
saw a guy Torry doing it the other day
and I like I like auditory but he was
like he was like yo like how many
followers this guy Torry have on
Instagram he's like a comedian he's got
so many followers and then like these
this is you you know who usually does
this is Instagram models because they're
not famous but they want to be and part
of being famous is having like dummy
accounts so if a girl has like two
hundred and forty five thousand
followers they'll be like this is a fake
it's not me and that that one has like
five account five followers and they're
like just so you know if this one is not
like of course it's not you the real one
has [ __ ] two thousand four hundred
and [ __ ] million followers but guy
Torry dead and I was like guy Torry um
how many followers is OJ Simpson half
debbie hilarious if Twitter verified him
you know six hundred and fifty seven
thousand followers dude that's [ __ ]
six hundred and fifty seven thousand
people who are like ah we know you
killed that we know you killed those
people but [ __ ] it I'll throw you follow
you know how [ __ ] disrespect that is
that's so shitty like what are you doing
dude and he was saying Twitter the world
is yours truly now coming soon the
Twitter you'll get this every time I
hear Oh Jay Simpson like I don't hear
him that much and then like a year later
his voice is so much more his voice like
hey Twitter the world is yours truly
soon the Twitter you'll get to read all
my thoughts and opinions on just about
everything now there's a lot of fake oj
accounts out there so this one at the
real oj 32 is the only official one so
it should be a lot of fun I got a little
getting even to do hey I got a little
again even to do
hello Twitter its oj simpson so
efficient so official account is a lot
of fake ones out there why does he turn
into a [ __ ] old I mean he said well
this is yours truly now coming soon the
Twitter you'll get to read all my
thoughts and opinions on just about
everything just about everything like
how black eyes are [ __ ] so
young-looking until one day they just
look 90 for 50 years right dude
if you see a black guy he could be
[ __ ] for real 12 or 40 and then one
day it's like when they hit 50 that's it
they're Morgan Freeman for 50 years and
then you're just no note or twirl
hey you killed two people a lot of fake
oj accounts out there so this one at the
real oj 32 is the only official one so I
want to know god damn I want to know how
he's how is he doing that
of course [ __ ] Theo follows him well
man I don't know maybe he didn't do it
you know there's a there's a [ __ ] I
believe in our court system you know
maybe he here's the thing about OJ's
there's a [ __ ] thing about how his he
was thought it was a thought he was
covering up for his son that's the only
conspiracy theory that's like all that
[ __ ] because you believe a father would
do that for a son and he'll never admit
it right but OJ was supremely jealous
and definitely probably killed those
people so it's all good so it's all good
hello toward world I feel like any year
he's gonna be like hello and then it
[ __ ] five years is gonna be like oh
oh oh um I can't like what is this world
the fact that OJ Simpson is on Twitter
it says everything as a South Park
episode
well my food the dirt spring them Terps